Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 5th,
2016 what's going on our why? Yeah. Um,
you doing your holiday shopping? Is
that what you're doing? Oh my God.
What do I get this person? And it's
just not enough time. Slide of bullet.
By the way. Slight Ebola is
still left. Um, yeah. You,
you guys are in the same
boat as me. Um, you know,
I handled some of the shit I
needed to handle. Uh, you know,
I got to fucking nieces and nephews and
all this shit I got to take care of,
so I don't know what to do.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to go on bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and click on
the Amazon link and go straight to Amazon
and kicked me a little doe. Rape.
Huh? Oh No. Bill, you shouldn't have.
Hey, don't worry about it. I made a little
bit of fucking cash. She, Sean, this one.
Oh, enjoy your remote control lab. Rookie.
Um, anyways, uh,
so I know the podcast is late. I was
going to try to do it last night, but, uh,
unfortunately I had to go to a memorial
service for my friend who died. And, uh,
it was a beautiful,
beautiful ceremony.
And also one of the saddest things I've
ever seen with these young kids and
everything. And, uh, didn't feel
too funny last night, but, um,
I learned a lot, man. I learned
a lot by going to that service.
I will tell you that because when they
did the collage of his life in the end of
it, um, the,
the photos and the videos and everything,
like 99% of it was about him
with his wife and being a dad.
So it made me feel lucky that I'm going
to become a father. Definitely. Because,
uh, I was thinking like, well,
what if I died right now?
What would the collage looked like for me?
And it would just be a picture of me
and a bunch of different comedy clubs
making weird faces. Um, obviously the
lovely dia, but you know what I mean?
I was kind of like a what
me playing drums. Like,
what the fuck did I do to keep,
you know,
not to say that you have
to have a fucking kid.
Cause definitely I think if you
don't have a kid at this point,
if you don't want to,
that's a great fucking thing considering
all the shit going on with the
environment to not just have another
person, just to have a person.
But um, you know, like
with all of these things,
the great thing was I got to see a bunch
of comics that I had not seen in awhile
and uh,
I will be seeing a bunch more this
Tuesday night at the laugh factory.
I believe the event is sold out.
So thank you to everybody that
came down and bought tickets.
I A or however the fuck you kids do
it nowadays. I really appreciate it.
It's going to be a, the money's going
to be going to a is a twin boys.
But um, anyway, so yeah, so I went, that
was a very, very heavy emotional nights.
So I did not feel remotely
funny cause that was the thing.
Oh typical fucking psycho comic.
I'm going to go to a memorial service
for friend of mine that I've known for
almost 25 years and then I'll come home.
Then I'll do my podcast after that.
If you think some of my shit
is bleak and dark. Um, yeah,
I, I'm glad I did not record last night,
so I had some shit to do this morning.
I'm a little bit late.
Um,
we're editing the season two of f
is for family and all that shit.
Have I made you laugh yet?
All I'm doing is telling you what an Arab
laid in my bed and I fucked it. Blah,
blah, blah. You know,
fully clothed by the way,
fully clothed this episode. Um, the NC 17,
Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast did not do well
in the ratings as far as the feedback.
You know,
it was something that we hear it.
Monday morning podcast industries decided
was, you know, maybe a different flavor.
We could throw the podcast every once in
a while I could just be wearing a robe
with nothing underneath it that Nia
could then comment on. And, um, you know,
it was like new coke.
That's what all it would say.
I'm kidding actually with some of
the funniest fucking photoshops.
I don't know if you guys
saw them on Twitter. Uh,
this Sharon Stone was fucking f that was,
I don't know how you taught that one.
That was great. So anyways,
let's, let's talk about life.
Talk about the world.
Let's talk about uh, hey,
congratulations to everybody up there
and the Dakotas that was fighting against
the pipeline. Evidently they've been
able at least able to stop it for now.
You know.
Good Lord.
Some of the shit that they would say
in those corporations with doin man,
they were playing for keeps.
They were saying at nighttime they had
drones and they would come in and they
had this pepper spray water mixture.
They was spraying it, the protesters.
Um, that whole thing is so
fucked up cause I was just like,
why can't they just go down to home depot
and buy some of those fucking things
that makes the pipe make a 90 degree turn,
go up the street a little bit
and go around the shit. Um,
evidently all the white towns,
the cowboy side,
I guess they tried to go through other
people's towns and they were like, yeah,
you're not running that shit through here.
So even the white people didn't want it.
I Dunno.
I guess what I'm saying is I
should have bought a Tesla, um,
until they do the research and what those
fucking batteries do once they finally
take those out.
You know,
I remember Michael Jordan telling me
not to throw out my batteries, you know,
I believe he was standing next to the
children. That's so together. Sneakers,
there's so much, you know, you can never,
you can never not get mud on your
shoes no matter what you do. Like,
how the fuck do you just like,
no matter what you're doing,
I do this and I'm not hurting
anybody or the planet.
Just the mere fact that
you're fucking here, you know,
somebody is crying in a factory
somewhere, right? Or the inverse,
if you're the kid or the person
working in the sweatshop, right?
You gotta be doing something, you
probably taken it home with you, you know,
coming home,
screaming at your wife.
That's my part of the concrete flat
asleep on right. There's something.
Who the fuck knows?
Dunno.
Maybe I'm just an arrogant kind in a
first world country. I have no idea.
But let's talk about Formula
One racing here. Everybody.
Nico Rosberg do diffs
level of fucking drama.
Like ladies, if you ever wanted to get
into a sport, but you just find, you know,
the four major ones in the u s boring or
you're not into soccer or whatever the
fuck people watch around the
world. Cricket, you like drama.
You like all of that shit.
I highly suggest watching formula one
racing this whole Nico Rosberg Lewis
Hamilton thing. Nico Rosberg, right?
He's the, he's the upstart guys.
I said he finally won his
first championship after
being a bridesmaid the last
couple of years.
This is my first year watching it.
So I'm sure a lot of this
shit I'll have wrong. Um,
he wins his first championship.
All right?
And then out of fucking nowhere
out of the fucking blue,
he retired. He just said,
that's it. I'm done.
And somebody tweeted that to me.
So I looked it up and I saw that it was
true and the only clip I saw was him
just standing there and his wife
was talking the entire fucking time.
So I'm just sitting there looking and
going like, wait a minute, is this guy,
was this her decision? You know, he's
got a kid on the way, just like, God,
I Need God. You really have to
drive again this weekend where
I, it's, it's just so silly. I mean,
you know, I drive a car to, you know,
I don't have to put a number on it
and drive around s turns. I just,
it's just such a male testosterone thing.
You're hurting the environment.
I don't know if he got an a rear,
like the whole fucking Yoko thing,
which people always says Yoko broke
up the Beatles, which I, I don't,
I don't believe that.
I think John and Paul kept
bringing their work home,
bitching about one another. And after
awhile, both Linda and Yoko were like,
Hey, well why don't you just quit?
I mean, you're not happy. Right?
And then they just threw that out there
and then the, their ego, you know,
like they were calling their bluff.
They couldn't be like, what, but here,
what would I do?
I work.
I didn't know if I could write
without him. Right. So they just, the,
they couldn't do that.
So they just fucking,
I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about. Let's get back to the,
let's get back to the race in here.
So I didn't know if it was that version
and then I read that. What's his face?
That was a Kiki Lotto or
whatever he was trashing.
Nico Rosberg said he made them look
silly and stupid and all of that.
And I'm just sitting there, why the
fuck would this guy quit 31 years old.
You just won your first one,
now you're going to walk away.
You know what? Why would you do that? And
then I was thinking maybe it's his wife,
he's got a kid coming along. He
just wanted, he was very emotional.
He had the come down
afterwards within this,
the little bit of a melancholy slash
depression. And then he like, fuck,
now I've got to do this again.
And you've got to climb back up the
mountain again. I don't think it's,
you know what I take?
It is, I think that, um,
Lewis Hamilton was the favorite son.
This is not just total
fucking guests at Mercedes.
He's sick of dealing with that dynamic,
you know,
and he wanted to get out of his fucking
contract and the only way out was to
retire. So he might leave for,
I don't know how long, you know,
and then he'll come back with a
different team. There's no fucking way.
He's not coming back 31 years old. There's
no fucking way he's not coming back.
He's going to take a year off, get
his kid up and running, you know,
get the kid to be able to
use the fucking shit. Right.
Mama Dada throttled
break. Right. You get it.
Say a few fucking words and then he's
going to be right back out there again.
You know,
I think he's going to be out there and
he's going to race for a different team.
But here's the thing though.
Okay.
Does Mercedes cars were so fucking good
that all they had to do was just get to
the first turn.
We haven't won the first turn right one,
the God damn race it seemed so,
I'm going to guess,
I'm going to guess he's going to go with
the red bull team because that was the
only a team that seemed to fucking win
anything this year as far as the shit
that I watched. But uh, Jesus Christ.
So Nico's get fucking trashed
people like what the fuck?
Five reasons why you would quit.
Um,
Kiki Rosberg calls him a contra
something leak. A Niki Lauda.
Sorry Kiki Nikki Colada.
I'm like combining the names here.
Slams Nico Rosberg for making
Mercedes look dumb dude.
In that last race with Lewis Hamilton
slowed down because if Nico Rosberg came
in fourth place or worse,
Lewis would have won the championship.
So he deliberately slow the fuck down
to let the third and fourth place guys
catch up and um,
and then he disobeyed a direct order
from his fucking pit crew. This is,
I'm telling you,
it's fucking top gun.
Yeah.
You know, you do. Characters
are going to top gun, right?
They tell them to speed up and
Louis is like, Nah, yeah, I'm good.
I can still win this race.
Let's just fucking ad 40 years of
stress to this fucking guy. Maybe he'll,
he'll spin out now when,
and um,
Rosberg's also talked about sometimes
you know when they're out on the track,
he doesn't know how far
Lewis is going to go.
He's going to push me off the track,
but Rosberg's done the same shit.
He did that like twice.
He has this fucking move where he
goes into a turn and it's like,
it goes straight for way too long and
then oops at the last second turns away
and drive some guy into the gravel.
Oh Jesus.
You don't know anything
about this sport too. Yeah.
Okay.
I Dunno.
We'll see what the fuck happens,
but that's my call I think isn't stay
home for a year with this kid. Right.
He's going to go out of his fucking mind.
As much as he's going
to love his kid much.
He's going to love wife the entire time
that Kenny Loggins song is going to be
going on in the background.
Well, Yay. Well,
but did you,
did you do fucking stopped itself?
Did [inaudible] though
YG being, I mean Bernie. Nah.
Right. Um, what about John at JFK said
and then the guy in the fucking pumps,
Eddie said, I am a, I'm an egg
or a cookie or something. Yeah,
it's going to drive them up the fucking
wall and he's going to have to go back
out there again and uh,
you know,
and then I think he's going to drive
for the rest of his fucking career. Um,
that's my guess. All right, so there
you go. There's a whole bunch of shit.
How often you hear a bunch of Formula
One talk on a fucking American podcast,
you know, nothing. I go fuck yourself.
Hey, how about that Patriots Rams Game?
You know, that's tremendous. If
anybody ever had trouble sleeping,
that would have been a great game
to fucking watch Jesus Christ.
I actually did.
I actually watched the,
you got to watch the game live with me
on Facebook was something last second.
We decided to try and all things comedy.
So thank you for the 1500 people or so
that tuned in and watched me a watch the
game. I'm sure they'll put together
some sort of clips from that.
MMM.
So if you guys like it enough, if it gets
enough hits, I might start doing that.
I want to do it for boring fucking
games cause if the game matters,
you're not going to want to listen to
me talking. But patriots first rams,
that's a good one. Right? And all
I do is I just do the first half.
MMM.
So anyways, I might do it with Joe
Bark, nick or somebody like that.
Maybe with Paul Versey at some point
we'll figure it out. So anyway,
so I have to go to this memorial service.
Okay.
Um, last night I was so proud
of my friend that, you know,
I could really see what a great
husband and father he was.
So I already knew the suit that I was
going to wear because you want to get to
my age, you know, it's fucking sucks man.
You start losing people and you
have your funeral suit. You know,
for a lot of people that was, I'm going
to a wedding suit and then that big,
as you get older that they come. So
I'm going to a funeral. Fucking sucks.
So you remember last year I got into
the best shape of my fucking life and I
went to put on the suit that I
fucking bought during that time.
Jesus Christ,
I could barely get the pants down and I
couldn't wear a tie to the event cause I
couldn't get the shirt closed and all
I did, I put on like 15 fucking pounds.
It's like how skinny was I?
And I was just sitting there screaming at
myself in the mirror. My mother, my, uh,
I know my mother always told me when I,
you know, I, she was always like fucking,
I dunno, she was always honest
about not being fat fuck kids,
which is hilarious to me because he
wants a fat fuck for a kid, right?
So I'm sitting there screaming at
myself in the mirror, right? And uh,
okay,
my wife is just sitting there fucking
laughing her ass off at me. I,
we'll go look at you. Look,
you're fucking disgusts me. Just,
just completely trashing myself. Cause
that's how I get myself back into shape.
So,
um,
I remember I mentioned last podcast that
I was going to do a half hour cardio
every fucking day this month because I'm
not putting on the pigs in the blanket.
Fucking apple strudel. What's a good
Christmas goes? What are you, yeah,
what do you, what do people have
Chinese food and Jewish people, right?
What's this shit that everybody
fucking eats this month makes you fat?
Fuck all of this stuff. The pies,
the cookies, the Christmas party,
the bows, all of that shit. You ended
up putting on all his fucking weight.
Then what happens?
Everybody joins a fucking gym.
Everybody joins the gym in January.
Right? And it's just fucking mobbed.
Right?
And all you gotta do is just hang in there
too about the second week of February
and everybody just starts dropping off
like the Bataan death march or some shit.
Right.
It was such a fucked up reference.
But I've been watching a lot of world
war two shit probably even said it wrong.
They said baton, like what your
twirl, the Bataan death march.
It was a bunch of high school bands that
had to walk to the prom that none of
them have dates too. Oh
Wow. And you know what?
I don't, but it's funny,
isn't it? Isn't it?
Um, anyways, so you know, it's great.
Why don't you beat the
fucking new person to the gym?
Rush on it.
You'd do yourself a favor and not
go into the new year, 1520, 30,
40, 50 pounds overweight. Let's
say you're not that dumb number.
What's that first number? Huh?
Unless you're in triple digits. I,
you know, I don't want to fucking
give it to him, but if he,
if he got a double digit
figure you're trying to lose,
let's say you're 20 pounds overweight,
why don't you try to get that
to down to a one, you know,
get that 18 down to a fucking nine.
Get that 20 down to a
10 just knock it down.
Run some fucking miles off.
You fucking know domino, right?
C'Mon admitted. Good. Nobody's looking.
Nobody's looking at cubicle. Reached down.
Reach down. Grab, grab a handful.
I look at you. Huh? That's so,
that's what you're going to
do. You're going to add to
that Jesus Christ. Come on.
Say it with me. I'm a fat
cunt, right? Just say it.
One, two, three. I'm
a fat cunt. All right?
Then the first thing you gotta do
is, is, is admitting it to yourself.
Once you've lost control over so many
of those fucking Christmas cookies.
But let's be honest,
they don't really taste that good.
A lot of them are bad shortbread with
some shitty frosting and some sprinkles on
it, right? You don't need
that shit, right. Half Hour,
half hour every day,
make a Goddamn playlist.
You know what's funny is I've actually,
because I'm so dreading doing cardio,
rather than listening to some
testosterone aggressive shit,
like I actually was
listening to like Paul Simon,
like my cardio thing starts off with
something. So right by Paul Simon,
which were you really listened to that
song? I should look up the fucking knife.
My Internet doesn't work down at the
fucking lyrics are really annoying.
He's like, when something goes
wrong, I'm the first to admit it.
Okay.
I'm the first to Ed made it, but
the last one to know, Whoa, whoa.
Right. So He's already said like, you
know, hey, if there's something wrong,
like I'm the first one to admit it.
I just never know what that is.
I don't know if it Yale, fuck
you Paul Simon, you can't.
I hate when people do that. You know
what I mean? They just, they know,
they fucking say that they're an asshole
and then they take no responsibility
for it because, hey man, I, I just
don't, I, it's hard for, for me,
it's just like hard for me to tell
when I'm being a total selfish Dosha.
My Paul, you know that. Okay.
Yeah.
If you could do a fucking sound check.
Okay.
And you can hear that the horns
are too far down in the mix.
You can't tell me that you can't be in
a car with somebody else and not hear
that you're being a fucking asshole,
you know?
And then the rest of it and
when something goes right, oh,
it's like you lose me. It's apt to confuse
me. Like he's just like, oh, I'll, I'll,
let's all stop and help Paul Simon,
you know,
that's why he married that Ed per cal,
I'm telling Ya. You know what I mean?
No fucking brought his age was
going to put up with his horse shit.
He had a good, he find some young chick
that was still fucking wide. I, you know,
slightly confused.
We are right.
She didn't know what the fuck she
don't know which way was up. All right.
God Damn oversized sweater walking,
walking around.
He fucking shows up. Like, you know,
I'm even happy if something goes wrong.
I'm the first to admit it. But
yeah, I never seem to know.
I'm like the last guy to know Paul,
you're a nice person.
I like see, you know he's
behind her just banging away.
It's fucking to pay. Slap it
off the back of his head. Right.
That's how the whole fucking thing
went down. And in the meantime,
he Brykelle the new Bohemians,
right? That you know, for a pop band.
I mean those guys could play great
guitars. State a great fucking drummer.
And what happened?
Vocat Paul Simon comes up with
his hat and hand showing up.
You know Paul Simon got, he got hair
plugs right after. I think Elton John.
Elton John got the original ones. So like,
you know, his head was so scarred up.
That's why when he was real coked up
in the 80s he was wearing like those
mannequin wigs because I didn't
know what I'm talking about.
I think it was I at the grocery store and
read a few too many uhs magazines. Um,
okay.
And it's all, how the fuck that again.
Oh, we're talking about working out. Okay.
Money had talk about Paul
Simon [inaudible] he's
fucking relationship I think
overstepped a few here, especially during
this holiday month. So I apologize.
All right. So I start with that.
Then I go into one trick pony.
Then I go 50 ways to to uh,
to leave you alone with
Steve Gadd on drums.
Um,
oh by the way,
he's coming to town with
the fucking Eric Clapton.
Somebody offered me a fucking ticket in,
I forgot to get back to him.
I got to see, I've seen Steve Gadd lied
before, but I never saw Eric Clapton.
But anyways, it goes to that and
then I go on, I listened to a,
what the fuck do I listen to?
A couple of pretenders songs.
Then I get into Aerosmith's first
fucking album and then I'm done.
Right. Just like that. I eased my way,
ease my way, you know,
we start off really easy.
Then I get to mid range and then I just
get to Aerosmith's first fucking one.
That's what I did because
what I was doing before I was,
I was like regretting, like not
regretting, hating doing cardio.
And I was starting off with like
fucking iron maiden or Dr feel good.
Do you know what I mean?
Like that's not like if you,
if you just waking up and you
get not a fucking elliptical
tall,
he's got the
just like Jesus, Vince,
Vince for fuck sakes.
Well he's got, at least I could
start with home sweet home Ryan.
He'd know allometry
um,
you know,
I just realized we have company upstairs.
Once I put the headphones on it,
I don't even fucking
realize I don't give a shit.
So I was listening to that and
like iron maiden, you know,
it's just like creeps you out.
Like you fucking getting on an elliptical
half groggy because I gotta go into
work and Shit. Right. Starting
your day off. We want information,
information,
information or why are you the new
number two? What was number one?
You are number six, right? How about
Vincent Price? I'll fucking work.
He got in the early eighties, man.
He was fucking crushing it, Huh?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Do you earth and sea for the devil sends
the beef was Rad because he knows that
a shot let him a lot understanding
record the number of the beast.
40 is a human number.
It's number is 666.
A public [inaudible] right.
He get he and then he was on fucking
Michael Jackson's thriller. Right.
Ah,
fucking crazy laugh in the end.
I can't remember the funk of 40,000 years.
I never really listened
to Michael Jackson.
Like I was one of those people that have
way to like pretend to be sad when he
died.
You know what I mean?
I'm looking at the bed in the mirror,
you know,
more date.
Right. It just never spoke to me.
I like shit when he was a kid.
Oh baby.
Give me more and more chance.
I liked right up to off
the wall and somewhere.
Uh, I dunno. I guess I liked some,
I liked some of, uh, like
Billie Jean was okay.
Thriller I thought was stupid.
You know, you know what actually,
thrillers in stupid, you know what it
is. It's fucking, whenever it comes on,
everybody has to start
doing the thriller dance.
And they always start with the same
thing where it's the claws up in the air.
I need this side. Always, always,
always somebody doing a fucking
Michael Jackson impression. You know,
you know what's
interesting about that guy?
As great as he was the Balsam
beat to critique this man is like,
he was one of those guys,
he had the sickest fucking dance moves
and then he just stopped and he kept with
the loafers and he kept doing the leg
thing and he kept grabbing his dick and
then everybody kind of
caught up and went past him.
Even though he was still always the
greatest dancer of all time. He, she was,
it was like he was doing the Charleston,
his whole, his whole fucking life.
Bad Gat though. It comes
the Moonwalk, right?
Somebody can't even remotely
fucking debts. Um, oh,
the fucking balls I've shown on
this podcast. Oh, let's keep going.
What other fucking legend can we,
can we trashed next? Um, yeah,
I never got into a, I never
get them. Like when there was,
it was always like prince versus
Michael Jackson. Like to me it was,
it was always print.
It wasn't even close.
And um,
I don't know.
Prince is funny because it's bad.
Songs always sound like songs that Molly
Ringwald would have danced around too
in like 16 candles.
Okay.
Like he's got a couple of those.
We just like Jesus.
I guess everybody's got those right.
And if he has one of those jeans belt,
can you trash any more
dead geniuses? Yeah, I can.
Let's go.
Let's start talking.
Let's talk about Mark Twain
in fucking Albert Einstein.
Is it me or did they both
have this same fucking,
what was it about being
a genius back then or,
or someone who was changing the way
people were thinking that you just,
you had to have that fucking,
that same fucking do.
It was Sammy the Sammy
Hagar and Van Halen.
Fucking do except it was white.
Right? Mark Twain had it,
uh, fucking, uh, Albert Einstein had it.
Frederick Douglass had that
with that fucking itchy beard.
Everybody had that when, when you
fucking are just too goddamn smart.
You know what I mean?
Like shit in and out.
You just got too much shit to think about.
There's something about that hairdo
that just, it's just the perfect thing.
I bet he looks back. I was like, why?
Why did I cut my hair like that was,
you know what their haircut he
got was like when he was younger,
when he had the longer hair.
That's like the chick you marry and then
like after she has a couple of kids and
she just,
I just don't want to deal with it anymore.
He got like literally got that
fucking haircut, you know,
just short of are you said that you,
you know,
are you moving towards an
alternative lifestyle here?
It's like what is going on with that
thing? That was just a bad fucking period.
Huh?
They were wearing those,
those peach fucking
flashdance fucking overalls.
Um,
I dunno.
All right.
Sammy Hagar.
I think Sammy Hagar would have been
better if he didn't join van Halen. Oh,
I'm going after. I'm fucking, I'm
talking about everybody this week.
I don't know what I'm doing here.
I think I'm going for fucking
a reality show right now.
Heavy that song heavy
metal by Sammy Hagar.
I liked that better. And you watch
him performing with his own fucking,
I'm gonna fucking tweet that.
Uh,
yeah.
I'm going to tweet that fucking video
of this week. You know what I mean?
You tell me that. Anything he did
van Halen, not trashing van Halen,
cause I fucking love those guys.
But I'm just saying Sam,
he should've jumped in there. He should
have kept going. He was on a path.
The man could not drive 50
bye. All right. Tall is
heavy metal, right? It was fucking great.
I don't know what happened
then all of a sudden,
right? I don't know what happened. I
fucking voices cracking. All right.
I think I've trashed enough
people that are way, way,
way more talented than I'll ever be.
So now it's time.
Now it's time to say goodbye
to all you fucking counties.
I gotta I gotta read a little
bit of advertising. Oh,
and there's a lot to owe a lot this week.
Everybody piling on trying
to get your holiday money,
trying to get that holiday
money. Oh, look who's back.
Look who's back. Always nosing
around during the holidays, right?
Oh, see, oh, Sherry's berries. Oh,
these things are fucking delicious.
No matter who you're shopping for.
Sherry's berries, it's the one stop
shop for everyone on your list.
No matter who you're shopping for.
Shammies be. Aries is the one stop shop.
I read that twice.
You don't have to battle the crowds
to get the perfect gift shop with
convenience right from
your home. Christmas. Um,
and it says example, only one week
away. Now I have to do the math.
Christmas is only 20 days away,
man.
So that's uh, it's only also, I already
did the day she cuts. All right,
what do you want to hear? Okay, it's,
it's three weeks and four days away.
That's 25 days left to shop.
Rapid. Deliver your gifts.
Choose a gift from Sherry's berries,
incredible collection of gifts,
and go ahead and skip the crowds
and the hassle altogether.
Who the fuck it somebody? Chocolate
strawberries for Christmas. The,
don't get these for your wife unless
you've got a nice fucking backup,
unless you put that on the hood of
a fucking Toyota class at that. Um,
why I picked that one. I don't know. Um,
this is the perfect gift for someone that
you have to acknowledge that you're in
your life, but you didn't have time to
shop for them or spend any fucking money.
Let's get down to brass tacks or this
is a great Acouto mom for a really great
gift. Okay? And it's fucking easily as
easy as hell. What are Sherry's berries?
They're freshly dipped strawberries
from Sherry's Barry started just 1999.
That's over 30% sits
around a fucking drinks.
Unless you're in a shit hole
that's over 30% savings.
So double the berries for just $10 more.
You can double up 30 bucks,
get twice as many berries.
They still haven't told me how
many fucking Barry's again,
you just need my code to
take advantage of this deal.
Can I get Barry Manilow to sing in
the background for Sherry's berries?
I eat strawberries there.
Make the whole world sing
descriptive words for berries. Okay.
Evidently I'm supposed to use these words.
These strawberries are decadent, fresh,
juicy, sweet. I hate that word. Decadent.
It's always used by dumb people.
Do is describe something you know is a
decadent like fucking something that's
like ornate. Another word I never fucking
use. They really use decking into disc.
Oh, have you tried these
chocolate covered pretzels?
Now they any good? Any
good dude? That decadent.
All right, there you go.
That's your challenge.
This weekend I want you to go to
a dive bar and I want you to you,
I want you to describe something as
decadent to a fucking bar flight with no
family to go home to this holidays and
I just want to please take a picture of
the look on the guy's
face. All right. She was,
Barry's dipped and tempting white milk
and dark chocolate. Goodness y'all.
Why the white come before the
docs on top with chocolate chips,
decorative swizzles and chopped nuts.
Any incredible unique gift that's perfect.
Oh, and incredible. Unique gifts. That's
perfect for sharing. Yati Yati do it.
I don't have time to read all this shit.
Call to action with Christmas.
Right around the corner.
There's only one way to get the
amazing 1999 Sherry's berries deal.
Just visit Barry's, B e, r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone at the top of
the right hand corner and Type in Berber
Cherries. Berries has something
for everyone and every taste.
Go to Barry's dot com click on
the microphone and type in birth.
Order them today. I'm gonna have
to blow through this shit. Ah,
may Andy's strawberries up your Ras,
but toto me,
Andy's me undies,
and it's where the chocolate factory is.
They rub up against your fucking balls.
It's like a horse mussel wrapped in
a rabbit ear. It's the softest shit.
Go Fuck yourself with God damn me
undies. All right. Picture a world.
Picture a world we're putting on a new
pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
Think about your balls or your
clam underwear is the best,
is the first thing you put on
and the last thing you take off.
Unless you Matthew mcconahey,
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Me undies focused,
so focuses solely on producing the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced. All right, for price, the
price of two fucking cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver your new pair of favor
and underwear right to your doorstep.
Jesus Christ is and on somebody's index
finger looking you creepy spinning it
around. Here's you'd run to wear big
boy better day guaranteed. Try them on.
They're not the most comfortable,
best feeling uneasy you ever head.
They'll refund your money and you get
to keep the first pair for a free.
These Uber Cozy undies are
sold exclusively on the me
on website where you can
enjoy free shipping in the U S and Canada.
Every other country can go
fuck themselves. All right.
For a limited taught hiccups,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar all right,
that's me undies.com/burr right
now for 20% off your first order.
Hey Barb. All right. Now, of course,
now I'm trying to read fast and
I'm getting the hiccups arts.
These next two ones are short.
Here we go. Tipsy elves, everyone.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year. If you want.
Bragging rights for the most talked
about sweater, your Christmas party.
Listen up costs. Tipsy elves has
hundreds of Christmas sweaters,
designs that are nothing
like you've seen before.
They're not for the faint of heart.
Check out all our new 2016 sweaters.
You won't find them anywhere else.
Tipsy elves sweaters are all about fun,
but are serious on
quality and construction.
While you're shopping
for your ugly sweater,
check out the yellow holiday
and collegiate attire for
yourselves or as a gift
like adult onesies,
adult onesies.
I've always wanted one of those with
the trapdoor to take this shit out of.
All right for me, for men, interactive
sweaters, beer pong, corn hole,
and Christmas suits for women holiday
leggings. You fucking away kick.
When are they not orange it up.
Jesus Christ.
Santa Claus has come and he's an old man.
You're going to give my heart attack
sweater dresses in pajamas right now.
My listeners get 20% off tipsy, tipsy
elves dot. Come on. Anything on the site,
go to tipsy elves.com enter my code
burr checkout for 20% why discounts?
That's tipsy elves.com and my
cold. All right, my code, my code.
All right. Then last one and an impact
to the podcast. Simply safe. Everyone.
Thousands of people seeking home
security get ripped off every day.
And uh,
and the home security industry wants you
to believe it's your only option, man.
They got who?
Woods of salesmen out there trying to
scare the fuck out of you into signing one
of those longterm contracts.
You don't need that shit.
You get stuck writing huge checks
month after month with no way out.
It's a robbery by contract and
it can cost you a thousand,
but there's a better way to protect your
home. Simply safe home security. Oh,
simply safe. Has No contracts,
none. You get award winning 24,
seven protection named best in
the industry. I don't know who I,
they could have been somebody at company.
They didn't say who said it,
they just put quotes around it.
A security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the police,
and it's just 1499 per month.
That's less than half of
what most companies charge.
Protect your home the smart way.
Why do they make peeping toms?
Just get into security.
Then you killed two birds with one stone.
You know what I mean? They get to look
in, they get their little hard on,
they rub it out into their fucking
awful fucking security guard pants,
but they're also making sure that
no one comes in the house. Right?
Would that work? I Dunno.
Protect your home, the smart way.
Visit simply safe
bird.com go to the right.
Go right now and you get
their free shipping on your
order with a free key chain
remote. We're 25 bucks. It only
takes a minute. That's simply safe.
bird.com simply safe dot comfor a why
don't I sit a wrong simply safe or is it
bird.com all right, let's get to some
of the questions here for this week.
Hey did you guys see over in
England there? They got the fucking,
they got some shit that we would
even make snow and go, God damn,
I didn't even think of that.
They got some snooping thing over there
where they're just going to everybody.
Anything you do on your phone or on
the internet or anything like that,
any of that shit,
they can just look at it.
Okay?
It's fucking unbelievable.
It's unbelievable how
presidential election goes by.
They never talk about any of that shit.
Why the fuck do you think that is? Oh,
fucking Obama by he was in office when
all that Snowden Shit went through the
big fucking liberal. All you pussies
who cried when Hillary didn't get in.
You see what the fuck
happened when Obama was in?
Okay?
Bunch of baby stuff. So
disappointed. Anyways, let's,
let's read some fucking shit here.
Here we go. Advice on the future.
Dear Bill Murphy, first of all, congrats
on the kid. Knew Special Yada Yada.
Thank you. I'm an 18 year old guy out of
high school and need, need career advice.
I graduated with honors. Good for you.
Straight A's. Jesus and all that crap.
But I currently don't attend college
and I'm working some shit job in a pasta
factory. Sounds like you're burned
out on the academics there. Um,
these,
oh,
he said this is because what I really
want to do is sing parentheses classical
shit,
take piano lessons and be happy.
My dream isn't to be famous or anything,
but I love music and want to pursue it.
Problem is, I have zero background, can't
sing, can't play anything. Literally zero.
There's a great place nearby where I,
I live that gives vocal and piano lessons
and all I want to do is start training
my voice and start playing.
But I feel like there's no point
because I have no experience.
Jesus Christ. Do you know what
it is? You one of these people,
you get straight A's, you an
overachiever and you're so goddamn smart.
Every time you come up with the option.
You know when the f the
normal level of fear comes up,
smarties like you can come up with like
rather than just 10 reasons not to do it,
you'll come up with a thousand and you're,
you're,
you're paralyzed right now
is what's going on. He said,
I spent my free, you're
only 18 years old, dude.
You know, nobody has any experience so
they till they start experiencing it,
you're already being way too hard on
yourself. He goes, all right. He goes,
I spend my free time listening to
countless covers of the same song watching
videos on vocal exercises and
fantasizing about being a singer one day.
I feel I can really do it sometimes, but
other times I feel like not even trying.
Yeah, I do. Yeah. That's a okay.
Dead first emotion where you
feel like trying to do it.
You need to listen to that.
That second one that talks you out of it.
You need to stop listening to that voice.
You need to out loud.
Tell that voice to shut the fuck up.
That's what I did.
I literally would talking to the, you
got to beat the fuck out of that voice.
That one that goes Nah. Yeah. Yeah.
But when it does happen, you know,
nobody's going to like me sit down
and shut the fuck up. All right.
I don't need you on this one.
I need you when I'm thinking about doing
heroin then I need you to go in like
millennia. If you get it kicked in and you
die, you make everybody cry. Yeah, yeah.
Then I'll listen to you.
But not when you're going after a dream.
You don't listen to any of that negative
shit cause you'll talk yourself out of
it. Um, anyways, I know you always
preach about following your dream bone.
It actually comes to doing it. It's
very scary. Of course it is. However,
I don't want to be 40 years old and think,
man,
what if my 99 year old aunt always tells
me to do what I want and forget about
money, but my parents say
that I need a real job. Well,
who has more life experience? You're 99
year old aunt and what is she saying? Huh?
Your parents that too close to you,
you know they're worried you're going
to be homeless and all that shit.
So they're always going to say,
just get a fucking job so you can have
enough money to put a roof over your head
and eat a sandwich. That's,
that's all they're thinking
of. Nobody dreams of that.
Nobody dreams about just having a roof
over their head and eating a sandwich.
Unless you're, I don't know, unless you
live in some fucking squalor. Right.
But even then after awhile I want
you have the roof over your head,
then you're going to at some
point be like, I want to do
something right. I Dunno.
Anyways,
I've been in between for a year.
I've been in between for
a year now and need help.
I don't want to get massively in debt
for something I don't really want.
That is so fucking smart.
All these poor kids coming
out of fucking college,
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in debt at this fucking point,
or at least the high
10 thousands you know,
that's what you love being
a fucking moron. You know?
Cause then you go to community
college doesn't cost shit.
You work at Dunkin donuts,
throw a couple of coffees of people and
all of a sudden you've got money for
your next semester.
Um,
maybe pursuing music will open doors to
majoring in music in the future. I Dunno.
What should I do? You Pale bitch a
PS. Give Cleo a head scratch for me.
Pimples are awesome. Um, and he says
Asian need advice from bill birth. Oh,
that's the next person. Is that
it? Oh, all right. Yeah. You know,
it's fucked up. I was going
to say, Oh, you're Asian dude,
you're going to crush the piano. It's
one of those stereotypes that I guess is,
but it's like positive racism.
You know what I mean?
Don't take up the cello. You'll be
playing for you fucking major cities.
Philharmonic. All right.
This is what I would do.
I would just start taking lessons
immediately. I would sign up immediately.
I would not listen to the rest of this
podcast. Hit Stop, walk over to the phone,
call the number and get a lesson as
soon as you can go to the lesson.
Okay. And then keep going and,
and just see what that feels like.
Don't stop after one. It'd be like, well,
we would do one and I can't even play
chubs to get, fuck this. Fuck that voice.
Keep going.
All right.
Just say I'm going to stick with
this for three months. All right?
That's the big thing
with, with, with anything.
You got to stick with it for three
months in really work at it. Working out,
learning an instrument,
learning a language. God knows
I always end up quitting.
I can't even get fucking a
hundred days together. Um,
just stick with it and see how
you feel after three months.
If you feel like this isn't for me, you're
not going to have that. Well, what if,
what if? Bullshit because
you tried it so this isn't,
you're not making a decision that's
going to affect the rest of your life.
Don't look at it like that.
You just looking at the next three months,
the next three months are going to happen.
Do you want to after 90 days
still be sitting there going,
I have no experience.
I don't know what to do.
Working in a pasta place and you want to
be in this fucking pasta place and you
know how to play a couple of songs,
dude, you be fucking excited man. If you,
if you actually,
if this is what you really want to do,
you'll be at work thinking about it.
Can't wait to get home and
play the fucking piano or or,
or try my singing some songs, so
whatever. And then once you get that,
then that gets in your DNA and when you
have stuff to look forward to in life,
all of a sudden shit that
you don't look forward to,
you start looking at it like, why
the fuck am I doing this? This sucks,
you know,
I don't want to do this.
And then that gets you out of that and
you start going down a path of what the
fuck you want to do.
Then the other side of that is then your
whole fucking life is nothing but fun
shit. Then when you actually have to
do shit that you don't want to do,
like go down to the fucking DMV and
find the title for your Goddamn Prius,
right then you can be a big fucking
baby about it. So there, there,
there's always a price to pay. But
do, that's what I would do. I would,
I would stop listening right now and
sign up for those lessons and go in there
and just tell your teacher said, this
is something I've always wanted to do.
I'm just nervous about it.
Just fucking just say what you said to
me and they'll be like, hi. All right,
well let's, let's get you on that
dude. You'd be fucking playing piano.
That's how easy it is to
make a change in your life.
Just fucking pick up the phone,
say what you want to do and then when
it's time you show up and you do it and
then you're doing it.
You know,
you just got to get around all
those mental blocks. So, uh,
I hope you listen to me man,
cause you're only 18 years old,
so it's not like you're
50, 60. And even then,
I would still tell you to do it because
who gives a fuck whether you get
anywhere with it. But if you want to
do that, you know, you should do it.
All right. That's it for that. Okay.
Asian needs advice from bill bar.
Bill,
I love your podcast and your
really awesome, um, Asian male, uh,
Chinese with squinty fucking eyes and
can't drive for shit, dude. You know,
kind of shit on yourself. Um,
anyways, I need your advice.
I came to America, I guess I always
do. I'm a fall pasty con. Um, anyways,
I need your advice. I came to America
a year ago and I really love tall,
slim Irish German girls with red hair.
Jesus Christ.
I just miss, I just Miss B
and you're fucking dreamboat.
I think they're beautiful. Well, I'm,
I told him a blonde is beautiful too.
Never seen such beauty where I'm from.
Holy Moly.
The problem is I'm not like tall and
confident like white guys and I live in
Texas. Jesus Christ. Dude, this is a
fucking reality show waiting to happen.
I tried to ask this redhead at the gym
out and she won't take me seriously.
All right.
Time the fuck out dude hat off to
you for the fucking balls you got.
You came here from China. You've
learned the fucking language, right?
You're in Texas, you're at the
gym, you're talking Shit, right.
Gives a fuck. He went up to the plate.
He didn't get on base. Who gives a shit?
Talk to another redhead,
talk to a blonde,
talk to whatever the fuck you
want to keep talking to him.
So what do I need to do
to date a redhead now?
Jesus Christ or anything?
Cause I'm a red head.
Like I know like there's some
secret fucking handshake.
He said they want me to be their agent
friend, but I really want to marry him,
Bang them and have cute kids.
This is driving me nuts. I mean,
am I going against nature?
Is an Asian guy dating white girls
frowned upon and not accepted in America?
Thanks in advance. I don't really cuss
that much and don't mean to offend you,
but uh, wanting to talk and
act like you, Jimmy Chow out.
Um, yeah. Uh, okay.
Is his Asian guys dating?
White guys found upon it?
Like everything is frowned upon in every
fucking country. Generally speaking,
people are afraid of anything
fucking knew who gives a shit.
Literally like that guy before me
who said he wanted to play piano,
if he told somebody he wanted
to do that, you know? Um,
I think initially people be encouraging
or whatever. They'll always be,
there's always gonna be people
telling you not to do shit.
Is this what you want to do sir? Yes.
Then I would go out and do it. All right.
So it sounds like to me from
your email that you've, uh,
you know, I dunno. It's like, it's like
you just got into the majors. Okay.
It's the first week you haven't
gotten your first hit yet.
What are you going to do?
You're just going to quit baseball.
Go back down to the minors. Fuck
that. Keep, I would keep talking.
Every time you hit on a woman, you get
better at it. All right. And I would just,
uh, I would just continue, like,
you're doing everything you need to do.
You go into the gym, you're staying in
shape and you're talking shit. I mean,
I don't, I don't, I don't see anything
wrong with your game plan other than,
you know, it hasn't happened for you
yet. And um, this is something, uh,
okay.
You know it's going to take a minute.
You know,
if you can just walk up and talk to some
chickens, a gym, and get laid, I mean,
then everybody would be fucking doing it.
The reason why most people don't do it
is because they know that 99.9% of the
time you're going to get
the fucking Heisman, aZ , z.
This is my elliptical over here. The GGR
elliptical over there. Right? Fuck off.
Right?
And for all the women there going like,
can you just like not hit on us at
the gym? Can you just fucking, Nah,
can I just have this fucking place?
Hey, they make gyms for that.
They make the all ladies fucking gems.
All right,
the fuck you going to go?
They're working out looking good.
And then you're upset that a guy's
coming up and hitting on you someday.
Ladies some days they're not going to want
to talk to you. Take it from somebody.
Okay. Who the women, they don't
even, they don't even like,
you don't even like register.
Like I'm, I'm like, I'm a fuck.
I'm a sir.
I became a sir or mister like fucking
15 years ago and it's all fun.
All right.
Okay.
Boyfriend's obsessed with video games and
I know somebody just sent me an email.
Who is fucking Nigga talking about
some borderline sexual [inaudible].
Obviously that's not
what I'm talking about.
I'm just talking about a little playful
flirtation of someone who wants to fuck
you.
Boyfriend's obsessed with video games.
How far into this podcast am I?
All right.
This one was going to
be a little bit shorter.
I usually go a little
over an hour, but, uh,
that's what I'm going to
have to stop today because a,
I get to go into fucking
why gotta go to work. Um,
boyfriend's obsessed with video games,
a buffalo bill.
I love your podcast and I'm a huge fan.
My boyfriend and I love both.
Love to listen to your rants about
whatever bullshit comes to mind. Uh,
I myself have add and can find myself
rambling about something completely
different than whatever it was I
started to ramble about. Anyway.
My boyfriend has always been a huge fan
of video games and he can play them all
day if he could.
Uh,
more recently he has been obsessed with
one game in particular for the last
eight plus months and has really
put a strain on our relationship.
He will turn on is x block from the
second he gets home until about four hours
before he has worked the next morning.
Jesus.
So we pretty much spend no time together
and let some it unless it's me watching
him play with his friends. He talks
to his friends while he plays online,
in which case even if I
do say something to him,
he either doesn't hear me or just me.
I've tried talking to him about it and
he refuses to change or compromise.
It's even started to
affect our sex life by,
I imagine it would because
he has no time for sexy time.
We were both still young
and in our late twenties.
And I hate that I'm practically begging
him to turn off the game so we can cut
noodle in the sheets.
I've been contemplating just breaking
off our relationship of five plus years
because it's been this way for
months and it has only gotten worse.
I'd love to hear what the
y's Nia has to say as well.
Thanks for all the good laughs and
congratulations on both of use on the new
baby birth. Thank you. Um,
unfortunately Nias not here.
Let me see if I can get
her, hold on one sec. Okay.
She's on her way down. Um,
I would say first of all,
you've been together for five plus years.
Yeah.
Uh, initially my first thought when you
were doing this is what I would do if, if,
what would get make me pay attention is
I would just start going out with your
friends and just start wearing fucking
sexy outfits and shit and he'll get the
message immediately.
If you walk out the door looking good
and he's sitting there fucking playing
video games and stuff and he, if he
doesn't get that hint, then yeah,
you gotta be thinking like,
what the eff this guy,
this guy is more interested
in this shit that they,
what I'm doing over here with my fucking
Christmas leggings going out to a
Christmas party dress like a fucking
hot piece ash over here. That's,
that's what the fuck I would do. You've
already tried to talk to him. Um,
I gotta be honest with you.
I understand people becoming
obsessed with video games.
It's why I don't play them.
But to me this, I, I'm a,
I'm a bit of a cut when it comes to video
games. To me they'd say child activity,
you know what I mean? It's like,
what is this person working towards?
What do they have for a fucking job that
come home from their job and they just
play a video game for the
whole fucking rest of the day.
It does not sound like a driven man.
Um, that's another fucking red flag.
Um, so that's what I would, I
would just start building a life.
Initially I would start building a life
without him to see if he notices and
maybe you guys can get back to where
you were or if he doesn't notice,
then you already have a head start on
getting the fuck away from this guy.
So the lovely knee is here. I'm going to
hit pause and let her read this email.
Um, or I want you, if you just want to,
you can just read this while
I continue to ramble here. Uh,
it starts right here. My boyfriend's been
a fan of the video games, Yadda, Yadda,
Yadda and all that shit. So that's, that's
basically, uh, that's what I was doing.
As I mentioned a long time ago,
the last video game that I played was
grand theft auto three and it literally
consumed my life.
I would be walking
to the comedy clubs,
getting on a bus,
and I would be thinking about
the game when I wasn't even a,
I wasn't even at home. I'd be waiting
to go on stage thinking about,
you know, I'll finish this
set and I'll go home and I'll,
I'll use the cheats and I'll just go
on a fucking rampage and all that shit.
And it just kind of took over my life.
So here's the lovely Nia with her advice.
Oh
mmm.
First of all, can I just say that
this problem really sucks and um,
it's really annoying and that you're both
in your 20s and he's like addicted to
playing video games.
I'm sorry,
but that's a lame ass and you
need to move on. Seriously.
Five years,
five plus years.
It's been this way for a month
and it's only gotten worse. Yeah.
And you said you tried to talk to him
about it and he refuses to change or
compromise? Well it's just, yeah.
And he obviously has priorities her,
this video game.
I don't know if he,
is there something else going on and your
relationship or did he have some kind
of,
okay.
Something bad happened recently that he
doesn't want to deal with or something.
And that's why he's so
consumed by the video games.
Cause I'm just trying to think
like what normal healthy,
happy person and just all of a sudden
don't want to bang. It's broad. Yeah.
And hands over his live to a video game.
Like I feel like something happens and
he's not able to like well you talked to
quietly. Okay. Cause it's sticking to them
my face like well cause you do this,
he started talking.
All we all be hand that people can't
hear you. Oh okay. I'm going the levels.
All right, I'm so sorry. That's all right.
Um, yeah I I would not
necessarily say let's listen,
it's the video games or May,
but you can just say something
along those lines of like, listen,
I feel like I'm not a
priority in your life.
And if that's the case then we really
need to talk about this relationship
because if you're not into it and then
just let me go so I can find somebody who
was into me and it's going to pay
attention to me and not their x box.
This is what I was saying she should do.
She should just fucking dress like a whore
and go out that night and it just see
if he notices like just to
have like fucking, you know,
fucking STI highs on and all that shit.
If he doesn't get it then by highest.
Yeah, just dress like a
fucking whore. Their stockings,
they go up to your thighs and then they
stop and there's this glorious little
fucking hands of leg.
You're so old that you feel like women
are calling out and like thigh high.
It's like they're like saloon
mistresses like on Westworld. Why?
Cause I came of age in the
18 hundreds why you ain't?
Why you acting like you guys don't
always whore it up every fucking holiday.
You'll hoard up on your birthday,
your hoard up on Halloween.
You'll hoard up on Christmas. Sex it
up. It's called being sexy sex in it up.
Send it up. Lamb on the fucking
bladder. That's what you guys do.
It's different to be titties out.
Clam peeking out from it.
No, cause I don't know. I don't believe
in that passive aggressive shit.
It's just like, listen, why the fuck are
you answer this or not because if not,
then I need to move on. The thing is
though, honey, he has made his choice.
That's what I think that you don't
necessarily want to fully admit to.
He's made his choice.
He's more interested in the video game
for whatever reason he won't talk about
it. He won't compromise.
He's made his choice.
Maybe he's not into the
relationship anymore.
Is that a possibility?
Is it a possibility that he
or she needs to or it up?
She's saying she's like trying and she
was trying to like beg him to even have
sex,
which is ridiculous.
It could be that he is just not ended
the relationship anymore and he's such a
fucking pussy ass pussy that he's
waiting for you to be the one to dump him
because a lot of people do that. A
pussy ass bus, I don't even know.
But you know,
some people are,
they don't want to be the bad guy or
they're just immature and cowardly.
So they don't want to say,
listen,
I think we should break up because they
feel guilty because it's been five plus
years.
So they do shit like this to like make
you be the one to break up with them
because they're cowards. You know what I
mean? So it is possible. So in conclusion,
what are you saying? I'd
say dump his ass. Bye.
There you go. It's all right.
See you there. All right. Yeah.
You want to listen to me read
out loud. Oh God. I know.
Hilarious is a fucking baby.
Realizes that I'm not good at reading.
What age do you think they're
going to be fucking turnaround?
Kind of look up at me like mom doesn't
sound like this and you'll be good at
reading like children's stories,
right?
I walked into that one. All right,
here's some adult advertising. Ladies.
It's the holiday season. And you know
what that means. It's time to horror.
Kidding. MVMT watches movement. We get it.
Holiday shopping can be tough.
I don't like to sell.
We get it like I'm already bitching,
I'm not, or I think it's the readers.
We can't it. Holiday shopping
can be tough. It's more sympathy.
It's not hostility,
which that's your default
emotion is hostility.
This is more of a we, yeah, we understand.
Okay. Any excuse to trash bill.
I see how it works now. I played
the victim just like Paul Simon was.
Something goes wrong. I'm the first to
admit it because the last one didn't know.
Oh Paul, let's work on
your problems. Paulie.
Paulie, what do you got going on there?
There was hair plugs. Is that a wig?
Is that a comb over movement watches
all that give gift giving anxiety can
disappear with the press of a button.
These watches make the perfect purchase
for just about anyone in your life.
Guy Or girl, and remember
they started only $95. You,
you have heard me talk about
movement watches and I am
sure you got one yourself.
Now let's finish your holiday shop and
get movement watches for somebody on your
list.
This is great.
Move and watch us just start at
95 bucks at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 classic
design, quality, construction,
and styled and minimalist style minimizes
over 500,000 watches sold over 160
countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns going by going to movement
watches.com/burr this watch has a really
clean design and now's the time to step
up your watch game. Go
to movement watches.com/
[inaudible] join the movement.
All right, plow through these last two
here. All right. Ah, are old friends.
Dollar Shave Club.
Dollar Shave Club delivers
amazing affordable razors
right to your fucking door
kid every month so you
can get a great shave,
but raises aren't the only
thing you need the bathroom.
What about other shower stuff?
Right? You want to paint your tank?
They got the right colors for you. It
doesn't matter your skin color. I'm sorry.
That's the wrong fucking copy.
Turns out dollar shave club got it right.
They came out with a new
line of shower products,
shampoo and body wash called the wanderer.
Well,
I'm the type of guy who
likes to wash his nuts.
The fragrances are unlike anything
on the market. Is that mango? Yeah.
Suck it. There's subtle and actually
smell like real natural ingredients.
There are a lot of body washes out there
that make you smell like a teenager.
What does a teenager smell like? Hope. Um,
this meant in Cedar Wood bought mint.
Cedar Wood Bodywash is amazing and makes
you smell incredible meant in a cedar
wood. That's like it dropped ice
cream and like a fucking sauna.
Why don't you sit on those little cedar
wood things are before the naked Asian
guy comes in.
That American Asian,
Asian, Asian, uh, you got to give
it a try. Once you were in the club,
you'll see the pro. The products work
amazingly, the services worldclass.
There's no long term commitments,
no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever you want.
And Best of all,
they're giving away a one month trial
of any of their fucking razors for a
dollar with free shipping. Um, then after
that, it's just a few bucks a month,
gets you one day, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
At Dollar Shave club.com/burr that's
dollar slave shave club.com/burr and
lastly, but not leastly.
Yeah. Wait a minute.
Is it meant and Cedar Wood like
they're two different fragrances.
That's right.
It is Cedar Wood and Cedar Wa.
It was like peanut butter and Jelly.
Just to be clear,
one sentence meant in one sentence,
Cedar Wood.
I thought it was like peanut butter
and jelly or Turks and Caicos. Yes.
Building know that Turks and Caicos was
an actual place that was the worst name
ever.
He said Turks and Caicos as if you can
believe Turks or can't goes but not Turks
and it's the word and that you have and
in your country United States of America
and Utah like why would you say that?
And Puerto Rico.
All right.
Stamps Com with the holidays almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post
office. It will be packed with everyone.
Mailing holiday gifts and packages.
So what are your dough?
You use stamps.com yet dumped.
Fuck with stamps.com you can avoid all
the hassle man and going to the post
office during the,
at the busy holiday season.
Everything you would
do at the post office,
it's you can do right from your desks
except expose yourself in public buy and
print official US postage using
your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or
package the instant you need it.
Then the mailmen picks it up and I
evidently I use stamps ace. I do.
I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters. Trust me if
I can do it. You can too.
I'm a moron. So it's that
easy right now. Uh, I can,
I can get you a better offer from
stamps.com than what's on the homepage.
Sign up@stamps.com use my last name bird
to get a four week trial plus a $110
bonus offer that includes the
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinperthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible].
Guess what folks sets a podcast for
this week's, this week's this week.
And I gotta get the Fuck Outta
here cause I gotta go to work.
Got to go edit and edit and
add it. So, uh, uh, that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I will check in on Thursday.